We will now use the Bayes rule
in an important application
that involves a discrete unknown
random variable and a
continuous measurement.
Our discrete unknown random
variable will be one that
takes the values plus or minus
1 with equal probability.
And the measurement will be
another random variable, Y,
which is equal to the discrete
random variable, but corrupted
by additive noise that we denote
by W. So what we get to
observe is the sum of K and W.
This is a common situation in
digital communications.
We're trying to send one bit
of information whether K is
plus 1 or minus 1, but the
observation that we're making
is corrupted by a communication
channel, by some
noise that is present in the
channel, and on the basis of
the value of Y that we will
observe, we will try to guess
what was sent.
The assumption that we will make
about the noise is that
it is a standard normal
random variable.
So suppose that we observed a
specific value for the random
variable Y. We want to make
a guess about the random
variable capital K. Of course,
there's no way to guess with
complete certainty.
The only thing that we can say
is to determine how likely it
is that a 1 was sent as opposed
to how likely it is
that a minus 1 was sent.
How do we approach
such a problem?
Well, we use the version of the
Bayes rule that we have
already developed, which is this
formula that gives us the
conditional probabilities
that we want.
And in particular, here, we're
asking a question about the
conditional probability that K
takes the value of 1 given
that a value of y has
been observed.
This is what we want
to calculate.
So let us look at the various
terms involved here and see
what each term is.
First, we need the
prior probability
of K. This is simple.
The prior probabilities are 1/2
for k equal to minus 1 or
plus 1, because we said that
the two possibilities are
equally likely.
Then we need the conditional
density of Y given K. So what
does this assumption mean?
It means that Y is a standard
normal random variable to
which we add the value of K. So
if K is equal to 1, we're
taking a standard normal, and
we add a value of plus 1.
So Y, given that K is equal to
plus 1, is going to be a
standard normal plus 1.
What does that do?
If we take a standard normal and
add a constant to it, that
changes the mean and makes the
mean equal to 1, and does not
change the variance.
On the other hand, if K happens
to be equal to minus
1, then the observation that
we see is going to be a
standard normal plus a value of
minus 1, and that changes
the mean to become minus 1,
but with a variance of 1.
So if we are to plot the density
of Y, that density, of
course, will depend on what
the value of K was.
And if K is equal to 1, then we
will obtain a normal that
has a mean of 1, so it's
centered here.
But if K is equal to minus 1,
then our observation will be a
normal with unit variance,
but centered at minus 1.
So if we are to write this
in terms of symbols, the
distribution of Y is normal
with variance equal to 1.
So the PDF is given by this
form, e to the minus 1/2 y
minus the mean of Y. But given
the value of K, the mean of Y
is equal to k, plus or minus
1, depending on what k is.
So this is the PDF of a normal
with unit variance and mean
equal to k.
And it corresponds, when you
set k equal to 1, it
corresponds to this graph.
When you set K equal
to minus 1, it
corresponds to that graph.
Let us continue with the next
term in this expression.
We need the term in the
denominator, which is obtained
by taking a sum over the
different choices of k.
There are 2 choices, and
each choice has a
probability of 1/2.
From the first choice, we have
1/2 times the density of Y
when k is equal to minus 1.
And when k is equal to minus 1,
we obtain this expression.
And we have another term that
corresponds to the case where
k is equal to plus one, in
which case we have this
expression here.
Once more, this expression
here corresponds to this
normal with a mean of minus 1.
This expression here corresponds
to a normal with a
mean of plus 1, which
is this graph here.
So at this point, we have in
our hands expressions for
everything that is involved
here, and we can just apply
the formula and carry out a
fair amount of algebra.
There are some very nice
simplifications that happen
along the way, and we end up
with an answer that has the
following form.
It's 1 divided by 1 plus
e to the minus 2 y.
And this gives us the
probability that a 1 was sent.
Let us try to make sense
of this expression.
Let's see what it looks
like by plotting it as
a function of y.
So what we're plotting here
is this expression.
OK, if y is very large, as y
goes to plus infinity, this
term disappears, and
we obtain a 1.
If, on the other hand, y is
very, very negative--
so y goes to minus infinity--
here we get to e to the
infinity, which is a very
large number.
So this ratio is going
to converge to 0.
So we have a graph
that starts at 0.
It actually rises monotonically,
and in the
limit, converges to 1.
If y is equal to 0, then
this term is 1,
and we obtain a 1/2.
Let us interpret this plot.
If y is very large, it is much
more likely that y is coming
out of this distribution so
that K is equal to 1.
So the probability that K is
equal to 1, if we obtain this
observation, is almost 1.
We have almost certainty.
If, on the other hand, y is
very, very negative, then it
is much more likely that what
we're seeing is coming from
this distribution so that
K is equal to minus 1.
And in that case, the
probability that K was 1 is
going to be approximately 0.
Finally, if y is 0, then we're
just in the middle of the two
possibilities, and by symmetry,
either choice of K
is equally likely.
Therefore, the posterior
probability that K is equal to
1, given that Y was
equal to 0--
that probability is 1/2.
When Y is equal to 0, it's
equally likely that either
signal was sent.
This example is a prototype of
the kind of calculations that
are done in the analysis of
communication systems.
This is the simplest model of
communication of a single bit
in the presence of additive
noise, but of course, there
can also be more complicated
models in which we have more
complicated signals that are
sent, and more complicated
models of the noise.
But the general principles
of the analysis are
always of this kind.
We're using the Bayes rule, and
we need to write down the
different terms that
are involved.